está en el corazón de la tradición judía
en túnez situada en la isla de hierba la
sinagoga de griva es uno de los más
grandes y antiguos lugares de
peregrinación de África desde Europa
Estados Unidos e Israel fieles de todo
el mundo viajan para participar en la
peregrinación anual túnez alberga la
segunda comunidad judía más grande del
mundo árabe después de Marruecos pero la
cantidad de creyentes ha disminuido
significativamente en la historia
reciente en la actualidad en el país del
norte de África viven unos 1500 fieles
frente a los más de 100.000 de la década
de 1950 esto por las dificultades
económicas y tras la creación del estado
de Israel en 1948 así como las tensiones
geopolíticas que le siguieron la
sinagoga de griba es mostrada como un
ejemplo exitoso de coexistencia judeo
musulmana pero su tensa relación en
Oriente próximo y más allá dio lugar a
violencia antisemita en el pasado el
atentado suicida más notorio fue el
perpetrado por al qaeda en 2002 en el
que murieron 21 personas un hecho que
paralizó la industria turística de túnez
y provocó la caída del número de
peregrinos que la visitarían en los
siguientes años pero la sinagoga de
griva continúa atrayendo a miles de
personas cada año según los
organizadores más de 5000 judíos
participaron en la peregrinación de este
año que se reanudó el año pasado tras
dos años de suspensión por pandemia